Once upon a time, there were two noble families in the town of Verona.
They were the Capulets and the Montagues.
Unfortunately, there was a great feud between them.
Lord Capulet had a beautiful daughter, Juliet.
Let's have a party for our lovely daughter.
That's a great idea.
They decided to have a grand party.
On the night of the party, most people in the town were invited except for the Montagues.
However, a Montague named Romeo snuck into the party with his friend.
What a beautiful lady she is!
I think I'm falling in love.
At that moment, Juliet's cousin, Tybalt saw Romeo and told on Lord Capulet.
Please kick those Montagues out of here.
This is a party, Tybalt.
Don't fight and just have fun.
But Tybalt wanted to fight the Montagues.
Would you like to dance with me, beautiful lady?
Okay.
They fell in love while they were dancing.
The party finished and Romeo left with his friend.
I can't believe I've fallen in love with my enemy!
At that time, Juliet was standing at her window.
The man I love is a Montague? Oh, no!
Come on, Romeo. We have to leave now.
I must go back.
I have something to tell her.
Romeo snuck into the house again.
He hid himself in the shadows on Juliet's balcony.
She was still standing at her window.
Oh, Romeo! Why are you Romeo?
What is in the name?
If a rose had a different name, it would still smell sweet.
Give up your name and take me instead.
"Then call me 'love',..."
...Romeo suddenly stood and said.
How did you...?
Romeo just smiled and opened his arms.